Summerlin family says they woke up to a
man attempting to break into their
bedroom with a kitchen knife ending in
gunfire and now it happened this past
Saturday in a residential community near
Hualapai and Sahara that's where Ryan
mathey joins us now live with the how
neighbors and police are describing what
happened Ryan
yeah Brian Denise this family has
declined to speak with us directly at
the moment it's understandable
considering the incident that they just
were shaken up by but this incident
witnessed by several people living in
the same cul-de-sac as them and as we
hear more from these neighbors we're
learning more about how this family
potentially saved themselves from murder
the scene outside of Summerlin home
early Saturday morning a man bleeding
from a gunshot wound to his knee by the
owner of the home he just broke into
could you believe what you were saying
again I was shocked neighbor Heath
Horvat documenting the aftermath noises
in his backyard first waking him up
around 5 30. and next they hear some
yelling and then I hear a pop and then a
second pop and then I hear someone
yelling call Vegas PD call Vegas PD what
Metro Police tells us 28 year old David
Vale was arrested what neighbors tell us
he took a knife from their kitchen and
was trying to get into the bedroom this
after attempting to get into other
nearby houses eventually entering the
house in question through the back door
neighbors who spoke to the homeowner
says their baby sleeping nearby the
neighbor said he fired a warning shot
and the guy continued to try to break in
and then he shot through the door and
that's how the guy got shot in the knee
I'm gonna die bro Metro officers
apprehending the Intruder who neighbors
say had no connection to the homeowners
he was
Disturbed obviously we don't know where
the drugs or what it was the rest of the
cul-de-sac now buying their own guns and
taking other measures to keep themselves
safe we all kind of hate make sure you
got my number in case anything ever
happens a little bit more so than we did
previously
now the suspect is due in court tomorrow
morning he faces several charges
reporting live near Hualapai and Sahara
Ryan Matthey 8 News Now